dans notre série n'est jamais trop tard
pour bien faire les français partent à
l'assaut des multimédias de nouveaux
services ont été lancés cette semaine
sur internet pour faciliter l'accès à un
monde largement dominée par la
technologie américaine
reportage patricia charnolé françois
granier ils sont très jeunes entre 20 et
30 ans ils naviguent toute la journée
sur internet pour le mettre à la portée
des français
c'est le but de ce club internet aider
les abonnés dans leurs recherches et
leur offrir enfin un accès simple à ce
gigantesque réseau mondial informatique
nous essayons vous faire venir que les
français se réveillent notamment en
fournissant à sa vente de contenus en
français parce que ce qui est gênant
aujourd'hui par rapport à internet c'est
que la plupart des contenus et en
anglais club internet c'est avant tout
internet en français fait part des
français pour les français exemple le
menu du jour vous propose la cuisine
dans les milliers d'informations offerte
ce jour là dans internet sur ce sujet
l'équipe en a sélectionné quatre comme
ses recettes américaines en provenance
de san francisco où les conseils de mama
l'équivalente de notre maïté nationale
autre illustration
si vous aimez le basket vous aurez les
résultats du championnat de france et
l'accès au club de michael jordan
libre à vous de lui écrire une lettre
qu'il reçoit simultanément aux états
unis le prix 149 francs pour la
connexion et 77 francs pour l'abonnement
mensuel
autre pionnier de cette nouvelle culture
l'équipe d'info ni qui propose un accès
simplifié à internet et surtout des
rubriques pratiques ludiques éducatives
pouvant intéresser toute la famille
le prix 490 francs pour la connexion 199
francs pour l'abonnement mensuel exemple
des programmes proposés les jeux bien
sûr plus ou moins difficiles la revue de
presse avec des extraits des journaux et
programmes télé des dossiers
encyclopédiques
c'est une formidable bibliothèque
j'irais plutôt dans lesquelles au lieu
d'avoir des livres en anglais
incompréhensible comme sur internet eh
ben on va déjà les avoir en français et
en plus classés pour assister le plus
grand nombre à pouvoir y accéder
ces deux initiatives pourraient bien
dynamisé le marché français du micro
ordinateur vous surferez alors sur le
net
traduction vous recevrez à domicile
quantité d'informations c'est simple non